entre Pier Belmar et chniard euh pierre
charniard oui pierre chniardoui j'aime
beaucoup ces émissions oui je comprends
bien seulement là là en l'occurrence je
trouve que Belmar est tout de même plus
plus habile dans ce genre de chose je
veux dire plus habile que alors si vous
préférez Belmar moi je préfère toujours
car charniè vous préférez charniè ça
c'est c'est votre droit absolu enfin moi
je pense personnellement que que Belmar
vous dit pour ça vous me faites le
sondage ou vous faites le sondage
vous-même non non je je je demande je
demande aux gens ce qu'il préfèent
évidemment je peux je peux je peux
toujours dire mon opinion aux gens hein
toujours là donc pierre benmar alors oui
pierre benmar non non pierre
oui ah ben j'ai marqué benmis maintenant